how can we quickly square the numbers
that are close to the powers of 10
let's see let's take 12 squared this
number is close to 10 hence the base
will be 10
first we will subtract the base from the
number 12 minus 10 gives us 2 now let us
divide it into two parts the left side
will have 12 plus the difference which
is 2 hence the left side will be 12 plus
on the right side the number of digits
will be equal to the number of zeros in
the base
here we have only one zero hence we'll
have just one digit and on the right
side we will write the square of the
difference that is 2 squared on the left
we have 14 and on the right we have 4 we
get the answer as 144. how do we find 98
squared here the base is 198 minus 100
is negative 2 so on the left side we
have 98 plus negative 2 on the right
side we will have two digits as the base
has two zeros so on the right we will
find the difference of the square that
is negative two the whole square on the
left we get 96 and on the right we get 0
4 here's our answer now can you find the
answer to 102 squared and tell us the
answer in the comment section for more
such interesting matrix do subscribe to
our youtube channel